julie is going to be next in chicago hi
julie welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
it's an honor to speak with you both
you too how can we help well
um my boyfriend and i uh were friends
for about 20 years and became a couple
about 17 years ago
we were both divorced at the time he has
three kids i have two
kids they all five of them are beautiful
amazing kids
all wonderful adults now um the thing is
is that i'm we've always raised our kids
in separate households
so we've never you know lived together
we've not combined anything together
and i'm going to be 55 this year um he's
going to be 53.
so i'm wondering at this point now that
the kids are adults
should we get married at this point
because um
and you know i've been told that there's
a marriage penalty
um his income is um higher than mine
significantly higher than mine mine fell
because of kovid unfortunately
but um if we combine households then
i'll lose
head of household and then i'll be added
in and then be at a higher tax rate
so i was just wondering what you thought
about that yeah
um you won't be a significantly higher
tax rate there may be a little bit of a
bump married filing jointly
but very little and here's the thing
um to me that is a
minor issue if you're 55 years old
you love this guy and you want to spend
the rest of your life with him get
married
you've been together y'all
y'all been together 17 years yeah
painter get off the ladder
[Laughter]
so i just you know it we we both want to
we were just
like i said kind of concerned we've
heard so many naysayers about
you know combining income well there's a
lot of people out there
there's a lot of people out there that
have little small lives
you're not one of them have a big life
get married
wonderful julia you're you're halfway
done
you're halfway down the aisle well
you're all the way no y'all are done
down the aisle you're 17 years together
but i'm saying you're halfway done with
your life you're going to live to be at
least 110 julia i can tell by the joy
in your voice on on the phone
talking about test drive in the car you
have test drove in this car for the
better part of two decades i think
yeah yeah get married and listen
you're here's the other thing there's um
there is some actual statistical data
that's
in the in the tax law that may or may
not cause you to pay slightly higher
taxes there's a lot of other data
that says that people who are married
have a higher tendency to prosper than
singles
in their careers in their wealth
building the combined household is much
more powerful mathematically
uh and so anything that you lose in
a little bit of taxes you're going to
gain back probably 10x
by the quality of your life going up and
as a result a lot of your
health issues go down your married
people
live longer that they do make more money
on average
there's tons of data that shows they
call it the marriage lift
in the financial world that married
married people just have a higher
tendency to prosper
it's not so you can't do it single but
there's a
uh you know whatever you whatever
downside there is in the tax law
you know it's going to be a lot of
upside on the other and combining
households and combining
your finances is an exciting adventure
it's called living life together that's
right
and she she's got the back half the kids
are gone she just gets to create this i
mean you're walking in
the universe you're walking in his empty
nest
you got the best part to go yeah this is
great